what is this
i play the black pieces
wait what he said it says i play the
black pieces
this is this is so broken i
okay what that's that's so mean
no i play white no no i play black
who is your favorite who is your
favorite chess champ
i said sewer squirrel next okay yeah i'm
sorry i forgot i i i i next game
i mean i have to finish playing this
this mad
mode with nothing but knights in
it uh my favorite chess champion is
probably by far magnus because of
because of the way he plays you know
it's just he just applies so much
pressure and
you know he's you know he's very good
at it
he applies
insane amount of pressure and uh and and
makes very
very sound practical choice practical
decisions
nightmare yeah yep pretty much
isn't this just a draw like look oh my
god like what is this
wait my opponent has an advantage
he has more nights developed
i have three nights still still still on
the on the edge
i need to get my net into the game as
quickly as possible come on
it's probably going to be a draw like
it's so it's probably so it's going to
be so hard to win like knights cover
everything
this game would be yeah what is this
what is temptation look at it
oh god
uh oh wait i'm gonna lose this knight
right i'm gonna do this this this
uh aaron day thanks for the fall
yeah
it's it's play from the position it's
this gentleman right here who
wanted to play that nothing but knights
against me so
i obliged and here we are
this loses a night doesn't it
all right so wait i mean
can this position be one even like what
what what what needs to happen for me to
win even if i win a night okay i win
oh my god
we did it
ladies and gentlemen we did it
i think we did it yeah look
it's amazing it hap it's happening
i can't believe you did it wow that's so
cool
boom
it's a mate it's a checkmate it's a
checkmate in the middle of the board
with all knights
i started wandered i was like wait we
did it and then oh no oh no my knight
and then boom